back here on the riches and show our
buddy Taylor on Taylor do I even need to
ask you a question you just want to go
what do you think yeah
Odyssey you've got having a little laugh
I turned that sound by you like that huh
yeah I mean it's just the reality of
situation I can't have the penalties
I've had it's just it's crazy the drive
stalling just killing I mean I often had
a hard time didn't go in this unit
definitely doesn't help with me coming
back after four games and having the
amount of penalties I've had I mean I
mean taking responsibility it's not hard
for me to do because it's I know it's an
issue you know I mean my job my
stop-loss has always been to play as
hard as we can always and you know I had
some I had a stupid flag I had a stupid
flag holding in a and a false start
yesterday so three penalties just
absolutely ridiculous and you know I
know Titan fans are not too happy with
me right now and I know my teammates
shouldn't be happy with me but I'm
definitely I think I said later in the
interview I'm not gonna hold my wife's
hand this is higher by week because I
don't wanna get a holding call you know
a picture of me laughing on Instagram
yeah we I was I was a penalty flag two
years ago as a joke and she she posted
instead I thought Halloween was over Wow
here we are with more penalties I know I
was ripping me now no I know that but
Taylor you know how it works you can
grab for just a split second then you
gotta let go you know and i mean so you
can't hold your wife's hand for just a
little bit and then let go let go so
you're not called you're not flagged for
it you know you know but again it's just
so Wendy obviously you're in the flow of
a game and it's exciting the way that
you guys won but then it went when does
it hit you that oh gosh I know I mean I
need to talk about this stuff and then
you were gonna handle it that way
walk me through your process Taylor
posting okay when you get when you get a
penalty that this thing you need to do
is move on because you if you start
focusing on things you start playing
start to add up that happened to me this
week I you know I had a personal foul I
pushed her to push the guy into the pile
after the whistle was over it was stupid
and then we call a stream though to the
left where I get out and I look at the
safety and I see the
I'm like oh my god you're about to make
up for everything here we go time to
save the day John Doe gets the ball gets
upfield amazing I get on this this
safety I start driving them he tries to
get off I put them in the ground and
there's another holding call so you just
you can't let those things stack up I'll
tell you what um it's just it's a
frustrating thing and what the game was
over I knew I had to talk about it
because I knew I know it's a problem and
I have no issue talking about a problem
sir if there is one but when you're in
the game I mean when those things happen
you got to move on and turn it make up
for it you know later down the line with
a good pass protection given to any time
or or good run block to go for a
touchdown so I think the next series
actually we're hitting one play for that
long Derek Henry touchdown right and I
went off and I pulled the old line thank
you so much for me not looking like a
complete a hole you know saving me for
those for those penalties boys I love
you guys so I mean I'm very aware of
this I gotta be better man I really do
so before we turn the page on this
subject you mentioned at the top of your
soliloquy here on this show that you
missed the four first four games due to
suspension and that was in that
four-game period where even fellow
Michigan man Tom Brady had it tweet out
about all the flags for holding like hey
I got to turn the game off is it
possible that you're going through the
adjustment period now that the rest of
the league went through for the first
four weeks on this subject yeah I mean
first off before that's a tough question
to answer after you just took
responsibility for everything and then
to go say well yeah that's probably
wretched you know I don't want to be
sure that everyone knows I'm taking
responsibility but in a lot of ways
there are things when you don't play for
four games you miss out on a lot of
stuff and so I got to be better about
those things it's it's a different
league then even when I first got here
my first year there's so many different
rules now and different ways you have to
block guys and and all that it's um it's
just it's really different now and I
mean I am adjusting a little bit and I
I'm sure I'd like to think it wouldn't
be as bad if I start with the first four
games but the reality is I mean I'm in
the position I am with there's many
penalties I have in the last five games
and it's just got to be better or six
games so I mean responsibility I should
I take it take it and move on and keep
going 1001
Titans offensive lineman here on the
Rich Eisen show take me in the locker
room here with a quarterback switch that
that can't be easy
it's got to be certainly for an
offensive lineman potentially awkward
how has that been in terms of the
transition from a guy that you have
known to win games for you playoff game
as a matter of fact with Marcus Mariota
and now Ryan Tannehill who has three
comeback wins in his first four games
here yeah I mean first off Marcus is a I
mean he ever anyone who's ever met him
knows he's the nicest guy in the world
and he is a pro's Pro man he handles
everything with grace and and poise and
there I don't think there's another
person I was a handle in the situation
as good as Marcus has handled it he's in
it he's around just as much as he was
before he's you know I think after my
penalties yesterday Marcus even came up
to me or as I hey man it is what it is
like you just got to keep doing keep
being yourself like he he's still
leading this team from a back seat and
so he's done a great job and I mean
Tami's come in and doesn't he's let us
spark him he's done he sits in that
pocket man he moves in that pocket so
well and he just ripped some balls so
the both those guys have done an amazing
job and I'm I'm very proud of both of
them and in terms of you know from five
and five I mean Super Bowls have been
won from this position Taylor I mean
what are you guys talking about in the
locker room as you head to your bye week
after after a win over the Chiefs and
the defending MVP coming back from an
injury that everybody thought would just
put the Chiefs back in the driver's seat
in the winning seat yeah I mean I don't
think anybody believed we were gonna win
that game except for the guys in the
locker room before the game and so just
to go out there it did not start well I
mean the way to beat the Chiefs is to
keep their offense off the field and to
run the clock out run the ball and we
didn't do that at all they they killed
us in time of possession our defenses on
the field they had like 80 plays and our
offense I mean we we score points we
just ended up scoring points when it
mattered and it's a it's a big deal it's
a big deal for the boys right now it's a
good showing the bye week with this kind
of energy we've needed this but I mean
like you said Super Bowls have been won
this way I mean they four five and five
I think the only goal right now is to go
and be consistent because that's what
the Titans haven't been at least since
I've been here is the ebbs and flows of
you got a win then you go down and it's
like
one with loss or another loss and ego
two wins and so being consistent I mean
we're in the back half of the season and
there's you know everything we want is
still up for grabs
yeah I mean in the last six games
foreign division home for Jacksonville
at Indianapolis you're let to your last
three are against Houston which is
currently winning the division and then
the other games you're visiting Oakland
which may be a potential wildcard tie
break for you guys if the division
doesn't wind up somehow in your back
pocket and then home for New Orleans I
mean those six games those are six
serious games you you can make some hay
no doubt about that against some serious
opponents Taylor there's no doubt about
that no question no question obviously
you want you know those five games
because we had back in certain ways so
we'd be in a better position but I mean
it is what it is and right now I mean
all that matters of those next six games
and it starts with Jacksonville next
week okay man what are you gonna do in
the bye week I think you get texted me
that but I'm just walk you through to
the next thing I want to talk with you
about what are you doing in the by would
look all baby we're going we're going to
Michigan I'm going to Michigan for the
Michigan Michigan State game and we're
gonna dummy those fools they have no
idea gonna be amazing you know what what
Michigan can do is continue the momentum
that they've been building since the
second half of that Penn State came and
essentially even though Michigan State
has said completely otherwise
essentially end the Dantonio era which
you know has been a thorn in the side of
Michigan not the last two out of the
last three games but it's been a thorn
in the side Taylor this this is been
this is very very big time at this visit
is a big deal
I mean I mean I would never wish someone
we get fired or anything like that snow
Antonio wasn't at Michigan State a
probably a lot better for us especially
when I was there at Michigan it did not
go well for the boys but your ever since
that second half of the Penn State game
with a seem like a totally different
game team like I went to the first game
of the year I think was in Middle
Tennessee
Kevin Bleyer still owes me money for
that game we'll talk about that later in
a long nice but it just I watching again
I'm seeing as my wife was lose first
game I ever been back to and since I've
sent that left and I was like this it
looks sloppy it didn't it didn't look
clean or crisp
and then after like you said that second
half the Penn State game everything just
seems like it's starting to click the
flow their offense or defense is killing
it so I mean they need to go win this
game
a rivalry games you know it's always a
toss-up but they do win this game by a
significant margin and get it going and
then obviously at the big one against
Ohio State and that's a that's a that's
a big one there they're playing good
football as I think any team is in
college football right now well you're a
head coach I'm sure we'll let you know
about that one
when that one was really see when it
come I watched the game with him last
year he was so condescending he was
talking at me not with me you know what
I'm saying
mm-hmm oh yeah good you guys are gonna
give up a sack there that's that's great
I'm sure that's good for morale and your
sidelines just like talking to me like
that oh it was bad
never what am I gonna say I was one in
three it's a house day I was one in
three against Michigan State I mean it's
retort list I can retort listen I know
it's so difficult to be retort listen
you're gonna be around the team at all
is you're gonna see Jim what do you got
this community I'm gonna go out there I
think you know if they got recruits Matt
I'm a bad I'm a promote recruit guy when
I was at Michigan man I was I was the
ace in the hole
I was the finisher how do you mean what
do you miss the guys out we had a great
time I miss everywhere man so so I'm
going there shake some hands kissing
babies and and hopefully get a couple
commitments get a little commitment hey
Taylor and again the whole that's good
for holding right there hold on oh and
don't and don't let go on that front
last thing have you put a motor in the
bus for your podcast bus and with the
boys is the bus it does the bus move yet
Taylor is a rust bucket it's beautiful
we love it so much I just bought a
Cummins diesel engine for it and the
first stop this bus is making is in LA
to see you okay it'll be done in January
yes we're getting mobile baby subscribe
rate 5 stars thank you so much Yuri bet
oh okay so now cuz this is what I
counselled you to do when you were on
our show
at the draft last year in Nashville
which is by the way amazing that was
just amazing they
oh my god I can't wait for the draft to
go back there I told you to put an
engine in the bus and you're finally
gonna do it so here's what we could do
you bring the bus right here we can
clear it to come right here on campus
here at 18t because honestly I don't
want to go any further than the front
door here we'll park it here and then
we'll tape it here how does that sound
will record the pod here a bus an
electrostatic about all of that looks
good Taylor let me focus on these next
six games okay brother you got it these
playoffs
well next next seven games you got one
this weekend in Ann Arbor and I want you
to bring all your energy that one to
Taylor you're right yeah I'll leave I'll
leave the penalties behind me you got it
bro thanks for the call you too that's
act a little one on twitter and act a
little one on instagram follow them on
both you should for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app